hello everyone this next game comes as a
suggestion from a subscriber and since
we started the day with a 10 year old
defeating a grandmaster I thought this
would be a fantastic follow-up this game
was played in 2017 it was played in May
it's played between Aditya Mittal and
Nia's Murshid the game was played in the
10th Kait international tournament in
India
Aditya here is a 11 year old candidate
master from India and Nia's Marshall is
a grandmaster from Bangladesh
so definitely quite a matchup and if he
you can see young Aditya Mittal here he
really looks like a happy camper but as
you'll see in this game he's quite the
ferocious beast so let's see this game
and for those of you who enjoy a nice
game of the Queens gambit declined this
will be quite a treat Aditya has the
white pieces and he plays d4 we have d5
c4 and c6 declining the gambit Knight to
c3 Bishop to b4 Knight to f3 and Knight
to f6
D'Argo's in defense seek after Sundy 5e
captors on d5 and Bishop to g5 now
developing a piece pinning the night
always wall and that beat 37 we have III
and c5 now Bishop to e2 Queen to a5
threatening to capture the denied and
then capture the pawn with the Queen but
Aditya simply castles here we have
Bishop captures B captures and here
what's the idea here can you capture the
pawn on c3 well you can but if you play
Queen captures pawn on c3 then rook to
c1 and wife will get a lot of
development for the c3 pawn and he can
always a recapture on c5 for example
rook to see one Queen to a5 and D
captures on c5 it's not really not
really a good idea to capture if you
captured and Bishop captures on g5 and
maybe coming and after G captures on a5
Queen captures on d5 and black is black
has totally fallen apart so after this B
captures on c3 a principled move well
maybe not a principled move but
definitely an interesting would be c4
lock in whites light square bishop and
it will it will take quite some time to
untangle from this position but after
and then of course 9 3 4 is coming you
can always then attack the c2 reborn but
after this be captures on c3 Knight to
e4 immediately now attacking the dark
spear fisherman g5 also now with a
double attack on c3 we have C for now
and Knight to c3 attacking the Queen and
the light square bishop we have Queen to
c2 and Knight captures Bishop Queen
captures Bishop and now comes D captures
on c4 Queen captures and C 4 C capture
Sun before and again Queen captor Sun
before and after this series of
exchanges the material is equal it's a
it's slightly better position for white
but I mean what does have a pawn
majority on the coup on the King side 4
to 3 and Grandmaster Mar shot here has a
two-to-one advantage in the points on
the Queen side so this is probably what
he was counting on and he thought he
would soon create a passed pawn here and
pushed for the win but in this position
he castled and we had rook a to C 1
Knights the B 6 and here what definitely
has a couple of options white can go up
to c5 maybe Bishop to e7 even sacrifice
the a to point here White will get a lot
of activity for this pawn but here in
this position as you can see young metal
you can't spell metal without doll in
this position he played Bishop to f6 and
this is this is quite the move it seems
like a weird move but it's actually it's
actually a brilliant move black is
actually forced to lose upon here best
best idea best idea for black here to
defend would be something like Queen to
a for allowing Bishop captures on g7
Queen captures Bishop captures and she
would have to play this play the same
game being up on down but after this
Bishop to f6 move the Grandmaster
decided to accept
Challenge and play the G captures on f6
and now now white gains so much activity
he plays rook the c5 bringing the rook
into the game with tempo and then we'll
transfer it to the to the King side to
join the attack and here from the the
best idea probably would be to capture
an a2 Queen captures a 2 and after Queen
captures on f6 now play Knight to d5
this comes with a temple on the Queen
and also you're not allowing the rook to
play rook to g5 checkmate
so after this you to stop for White's
threats below I can't seem to click wind
you five checking h8 and grab the piece
back so you know the material is still
equal here but you know you have an open
King and a change it will be hard for
black to defend this
so after this rook to c5 the Grandmaster
doesn't go for this he plays Queen to a3
with the idea that if Queen moves the
rook will be attacked so we have Rock to
h5 and rook to h5 is actually the only
move that still gives a white the
advantage after sacrifice rook to e8 now
making room for the King on f8 Queen
captures on f6 and rook to e6 now we
have Rock to g5 check King to f8 and
Queen to g7 check King to g8 and in this
position young a metal here played night
to the for bringing the night into the
attack would attempt on the rook but
there was actually a better move Queen
to HH check followed by King to e7
followed by Rock to g8 and this
completely immobilizes blacks Queen side
black can't develop any pieces here and
probably to even continue playing this
game
black would have to play Bishop d7 at
develop develop some pieces and allow
this rook captures on a8 Knight captures
and Queen captures but then again you
know it's it's a it's a hard hard call
to make when you're the one leading the
attack so after King to e8 he played
Knights the d4 probably preparing this
maneuver after the night already
Wednesday to d4
but now black has this rook to g6 idea
rook to e5 check the
- e-cigs blocking now the check is
blocked and also this comes up with
developing a piece now the route can
also enter the game Queen - h7 and here
Queen to d6 and this Queen to d6 is
actually you know it's not a blunder but
it's a pretty big inaccuracy with
something like rook the c8 black and
black and still play this game for
example Knight captures rook captures
rook captures pawn captures and you know
white does have this monster monster
pawn chain that he will start pushing
forward but it's it's hard to tell if
it's compensation for the piece and
white will always be able to draw the
game since the king is wide open on e8
but after Queen captures on h7
grandmaster moy should a Marsha to play
the Queen to d6 and we have f4 and
already now it's it's very hard to
defend for black now rook c8 isn't quite
as appealing for example rook to c8
white now has the option of playing
Queen captures on g6 and if you capture
the Queen then rook captures Bishop and
this is this is all over for black so
something like Queen captures on e5
would be played and after F captures F
captures on g6 and Knight captures white
would be up to pawns okay there are two
doubled pawns but still probably a
winning game for white if it played
correctly
so after f4 rook to f6 was played now
and this is actually blunder that loses
the game it seems like everything is
fine but actually it's not
Queen to h8 was played by young Aditya
Mittal and in this position Grandmaster
Nia smash had resigned to the game
what's the idea here well obviously if
you if you play something like King to
d7 you lose the rook on f6 so you have
to protect the rook after King to b7
what would happen is actually Queen to
h4 and there is nothing black can play
here
the rookie spend Knight to f5 which
check is coming for King the king and
the Queen so you have two options here
either you move the King so you don't
get forked but then you lose the rock
and f6 or you move the Queen something
like Queen to beef
or but then again tonight to f5 check is
coming again both rook and Bishop can't
move you have to move the King King d7
now first you bring another rook into
the attack Ruby one check King moves and
I simply capture with Queen captures on
f6 and it's it's it's game over white is
now actually up the exchange and and
he's up two pawns so there is no point
in continuing this game so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it so
today we had a ten year old and an 11
year old crushing grandmasters so quite
quite a you know a great day for young
chess players I would like to thank
Allen Asbury for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it and if you've seen in my
previous video I've invited you to help
me promote chess so yeah if you have a
nice photo or a nice video of you
teaching someone how to play chess do
send it there will be an email where you
can send send it to in the description
below feel free to do so and like I said
in my previous video I will mix all
those videos and photos together to
create a very nice you know video of
everyone in this community joining up to
promote chess so yeah as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon